out of
all the fantastic scenes that we've
witnessed in one piece over the years
i think it's this one right here that
for
some reason sticks out to me as
difference
an explosion a black hat gliding through
the snow
and then a painful silence that
pierces like an icy lance
when the straw hats arrive in this quiet
snowy world of drum island
it's a stark contrast to the hectic
heated baroque work saga that's going on
around it
and so the entire arc feels like a kind
of
narrative island in the flow of larger
events taking place around it
it's a beautiful and tragic story of an
incompetent but
kind-hearted doctor taking in a young
reindeer that has been rejected by both
its herd
and the humans after gaining
intelligence looking for
nothing more than acceptance and love
it's a story that works perfectly fine
without any knowledge about devil fruits
the grand line and even the straw hats
and yet despite this isolation i believe
that the climax of the scene
is not only one of the most emotional
but also one of the most
meaningful moments for the overall
narrative after all
it introduces one of the major themes in
the story
[Music]
over the course of the scene we see the
relationship between the doctor hero
look
and the reindeer chopper slowly grow
as we learned right at the beginning of
the scene both of them are
outcasts here look being seen as a quack
doctor by the people of the country
and chopper being rejected by both
humans and reindeers for his mixed
appearances
while the old doctor is quite satisfied
with his isolated life
and his quest to heal his country the
young chopper is at an absolute low
point in his life
humiliated hurt and abandoned it's in
this terrible state that hero look finds
the shot reindeer bleeding in the snow
outside the village
after he tried to befriend its people
and it's at this moment here that with
every story beat we slowly start to
witness his circumstances
change for the better herolog does not
abandon him as the other humans did
but tries to treat him at which the
traumatized and terrified boy attacks
him
due to his kind-hearted nature herolog
doesn't give up however
and after he strips himself completely
naked in the biting cold
to prove that he has no weapons with him
chopper allows him to bring him home and
treat him
experiencing care and empathy for the
very first time
it takes exactly three days for the
reindeer to reveal that he can actually
talk
frightened to be chased away as a
monster and freak again
hero look however knows exactly how to
take away that fear
and so he gives chopper the feeling of
being normal and accepted for the very
first time in his life
for the next year the two of them
develop a sort of father and son
relationship
and hirolog shares his dream with the
slowly healing chopper
to free the country suffering under the
tyranny of true law paul
who is monopolizing all of the doctors
he shares a story about his time as a
pirate and how he was able to heal a
sickness
that was believed to be incurable by
seeing cherry blossoms in a country far
to the west
this experience changed his life and the
mysterious power of the cherry blossoms
became an important part of his persona
this is not only wonderfully symbolized
in this panel here
but herolog also shares his very own
jolly roger
with chopper that carries cherry
blossoms as well
it is one of the main symbols of the arc
that also appear on dr correa's shirt
and even in the shape of chopper's
hooves
and so herolog ignites a burning
admiration for both medicine
and pirates in chopper and over time he
manages to warm the reindeer up
more and more
and he even gives his very first present
to chopper
a big pink hat similar to the one he
wears himself
however after roughly a year of growing
to love each other
in a heartbreaking scene hero look
suddenly kicks chopper out what at first
sight seems like another betrayal
quickly turns out to be an act of
kindness as the hero look has once again
caught an incurable disease
and doesn't want chopper to see the only
person he ever had in his life
to die before his eyes chopper however
overhears a conversation he has with dr
corey
the only other doctor on the island
outside of the king's control
and so chopper sets out on dangerous
journey to look for a mushroom that he
found in one of the medical books
during which he has to face his old hurt
and past
finally he returns to herolog heavily
injured but
with the mushroom in his hand upon
seeing him
hero look embraces him in a tight hug
and is relieved that his son is safe
happily he consumes the mushroom that
chop has brought him
and after saying goodbye to chopper
quickly hurries off towards correa's
house
here we enter the climax of the scene we
learned that the mushroom that chopper
has found actually
contained a deadly poison as he
misinterpreted the skull symbol next to
it for the all-powerful symbol of
pirates that hero look had shown him
and so after finding out what had
happened correa hurries to find chopper
and tell him the truth
and that kindness alone can't heal
people
here look meanwhile heads to the castle
where the king has set a trap for him by
declaring that all of the country's
doctors have fallen ill
finally he arrives at the castle and he
realizes that it was a trap all along
and that all the doctors in the country
were actually fine
already being close to death he breaks
down in tears of
joy at the news and holds one of the
best speeches in the story
and before walpole can order his man to
kill him
he blows himself up
i'm pretty sure that this might have
been the very first time that i've ever
shed a tear watching an anime
this scene here just hits home
differently for me in a number of ways
absolutely love winter and the snow and
so the quiet and peaceful design of drum
island as a location
already creates an almost friendly
ambient for me and a constant snowfall
carries a sense of calming serenity but
also of quiet
inexorable death and the way that oda
opens the flashback with luffy about to
punch waffle in the face
and ending with the punch landing is a
great use of portraying the flow of time
while at the same time making for an
incredibly satisfying ending
after seeing the fruits of wahpol's
narcissistic character
who are by the way believe to be the
only thing about this arc that isn't
really good
just imagine a villain of the likes of
doflamingo or crocodile in this context
and the entire plot becomes even better
than it already is
but this scene is a lot more than just a
beautifully crafted backstory for the
next straw hats
[Music]
just as blackbeard's speech on jaya
introduces us to the concept of dreams
hero looks introduces us to another
major theme of one piece
that is closely connected to dreams
the concept of inherited will is one of
the most
important underlying drivers in oda's
story that he has fantastically
integrated into herolog's character
throughout the show there have been many
characters who said they wouldn't die
and then did so gold roger's final words
to ready for example before turning
himself in were
and ace told luffy that he would never
die as well
and so when hero look holds his famous
speech despite all the emotions it
carries
it does sound a bit abstract at first
however as we learn throughout the story
this is more than just a mere metaphor
and actually you can ask yourself this
question in real life
when does a person die can you
pinpoint the exact moment doctors have
declared people that who they then were
able to revive
so it's not a simple matter of chemistry
or biology
this may sound like a quite
philosophical approach to this video
but remember the theme of a story is the
underlying moral argument that the
author wants to make about the world
some of you might think of this meme
here right now however as
anyone who pursues a career as a writer
will tell you
great authors that create great stories
do
think about this stuff a lot and so
if inherited will is a major theme of
the story
it does have a deeper meaning for oda
and so what this question really
explores is not to determine when
someone is dead
but rather what it means to live and in
oda's eyes to live
is to act and to act is to impose your
will
on the world and cause change we even
say that a joke is dead when it no
longer leaves any impact on us
a person is the same way
when a person is forgotten then their
will no longer exists in this world
but as long as they and the dreams and
ideals they had are remembered
their will will continue to influence
the world and cause
change through those that have inherited
their will by remembering
and so i believe that hero look reveals
the true power of this theme in the
story to us
inherited will keeps people and their
dreams
alive
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
as you can see the concept of inherited
will is
everywhere in the story and luffy as the
main character is of course the prime
example of this
the straw hat he wears once belonged to
roger but
upon his death he gave it to shanks with
it he passed on his will and
responsibility as a pirate
fighting for freedom and his dreams and
so through
shanks raj's lesson still changed the
world
and shanks has passed on that hat to
luffy
that act has motivated him to become a
pirate just like shanks
luffy has absolutely no idea where the
head actually comes from
he knows next to nothing about roger but
he's still doing the things that raja
would want him to do
because shanks passed his will and by
extension rogers will
on to luffy roger isn't dead
he's living on in luffy and shanks and
the entire
era that he has created the power of
keeping people alive through their will
is the main drive of the story not only
for our heroes
but also for the main antagonists
because the world government is
very well aware of this power and does
everything it can to stop it
it's exactly why they planned on cutting
off the live feed of asus execution
not just to kill ace the man but to kill
ace the ideal
and it's also the reason why they seek
to destroy the true history
the will of the people from the void
century passed down for hundreds of
years
[Applause]
whoever the person was that has passed
on his will until today
he is still alive as his dreams and
ideals still live on
and it is this scene here in the snowy
world of drum island that this
concept is already introduced by oda
and so not for nothing is dr kureha the
very first character in the story
to reveal raj's true name and to mention
the will of thee
what really rounds off the scene and the
drum island arc overall then
is that chopper inherits will as well
one on the other hand by dr correa who's
able to heal the body
but is too cold to heal the heart and on
the other hand of course dr hiroluk
who is able to heal people's hearts but
is not skillful enough to heal the body
chopper inherits both of their wills by
striving to become a doctor that can
heal
any sickness no matter of what sort and
here the circle closes
as this inherited will is beautifully
symbolized by
cherry blossoms hirolog's life work of
producing cherry blossoms on the winter
island
to heal people's hearts is made possible
by kureha
who not only wore them in his memory on
her shirt but also had mass produced the
powder for him
showing that she believed in his dream
all along
and so when luffy defeats wapol and
frees the country from its metaphoric
physical illness the country's cold
heart in the end
is healed by seeing the cherry blossoms
bloom in the night
leading to political revolution and a
better future
in a country that will now carry the
symbol in its heart and even
in its name
[Music]
and so in the end while on the surface
the scene may appear to be nothing more
than a simple
short story that is beautifully
heartwarming and heartbreaking at the
same time
it actually encompasses the entire theme
of the one piece story
making it not only so much more
meaningful but
touching something deeper inside of us
where we can't help but be touched by
feelings of joy
sorrow relief and nostalgia at the sight
of
cherry blossoms because above all
they remind us that people only die when
they're forgotten
and people's dreams never die
the ultimate antagonist of inherited
will and people's dreams
are of course the tendrio beto and their
tyrannical rule of the worlds
and so i think there is a scene here
that we do have to discuss as well
and so we'll be looking at that in the
next video
thanks guys peace